anti-racism in schools that was the
topic of last night's ccsd board of
trustees meeting and once again tempers
flared district leaders presented a
timeline for their plan to follow a
newly passed law in nevada 8 news now
sasha loftis was there for all of the
fireworks
[Applause]
turmoil takes center stage at yet
another ccsd board of trustees meeting
and dr martin does a great job in
understanding all the training parents
teachers and students spoke out on a
district-wide anti-racism policy our
children are not protected
they are not being protected many pushed
for progress demanding concrete policies
in schools now while others are against
any action it's become clear that
we're just not you know we're on such
different pages
and
we just have totally different views
this topic was first touched on back in
june after this year's passage of nevada
assembly bill 371 which includes racial
discrimination and existing laws related
to bullying discrimination based on race
bullying and cyber bullying on thursday
the first timeline to develop this
policy in ccsd was presented with a
mention of staff education and community
accountability i've already heard the
word n-word said to me multiple times
i've had teachers tell me that i don't
have a future because i'm black a final
adoption is set for january but many
students say they're suffering now and
they're asking for immediate change our
kids just have to continue to go through
this we're not standing for it to move
toward a better experience in the
classroom i deserve to go to the class
and not feel scared sasha loftis 8 news
now
the district also formed a task force to
help with the development of anti-racism
policies it was made clear that critical
race theory would not be part of any
plan moving forward joe